this webcam looks like it's sitting
perfectly straight um and yet it looks
like we're about to like fall out of my
room so I guess that's just how today's
video is going to look I'm sorry about
that we're a little sideways today so um
it has come the time of year where
everybody debates game of the year I'm
going to be honest I think this year's
game awards is going to be big I feel
like there are going to be a lot of
announcements and I'm excited about it
um that's mostly a hunch a couple of
things that I am aware of but um I think
it's going to be a good one I of course
could be completely wrong don't overhype
yourself about anything ever good way to
live so the game awards website the game
awards.com went live with um their
nominees people are as they are every
year upset and I'm sure I have made a
video covering this before but I just
wanted to do it again um to explain to
you why essentially game of the is utter
nonsense and how the jury works and why
it's utter nonsense and actually why
that's completely okay um so nominees
for this year's Game of the Year
recognizing a game that delivers the
absolute best experience across all
creative and Technical Fields sorry if
you can hear my dog chewing on his phone
he has a shorter life than us okay if he
wants to chew a bone in the background
of my stupid YouTube videos he can but
this is what it looks like Alan W 2
balls Gate 3 marel Spider-Man 2 Resident
Evil 4 The Legend of Zelda teers of the
Kingdom Super Mario BRS Wonder this is
my pick though I think Alan Wake 2 is so
godamn brilliant ah this is a oh oh what
a list it's a tough one overall because
there are a lot of people talking about
certain games being snubbed there's
certainly a sentiment that the jury is
all paid off by PlayStation even though
there's one PlayStation game and two
Nintendo games and so as somebody who
has been on various Game of the Year
juries I've done it for the game awards
maybe five times I did it for baa I
think I've done it for maybe six
different companies they all function
quite differently and I think a lot of
people don't understand how the game
awards specifically works but I can
speak to that the game Wars Junctions in
a sort of unique way in fact I would say
in the most hands-off way which is kind
of why you shouldn't care I mean I'll
elaborate on that further shortly I'm
not saying that you shouldn't enjoy the
game awards I love it it's a show that I
really enjoy watching every year we'll
get to that I'm getting ahead of myself
so this is what the jury for the game
awards looks like okay it is very big
jury um of a lot of people from all over
the world who often don't even speak the
same languages the suggestion of
collusion here is frankly ridiculous uh
this is far too many people from far too
many outlets for collusion to even be
able to coordinate like it just it keeps
going and going and going it is a very
very very long list of people so the way
that other events that I have been on
the jury 4 function um the one that's
most involved is bafta in my experience
you have to play every single game they
require you to play them all they will
give you keys for every single game you
don't have to finish them that functions
essentially across all of these um how
would they know if you finish games on
all and I think it would be interesting
to do specific game award to people
whove only finished the games they play
but it like can make the jury so small
so I don't know if there's really that
much advantage to it but then you debate
effectively like you have um several
Zoom calls or whatever where you would
sit with these people who are also on
your jury panel all of whom have been
selected from usually different Dev
Studios or different Outlets media
Outlets so they're from different
countries and have different skill sets
and you basically get in a room and
every single person has to give their
case for which game or why or why they
didn't like a certain game everybody has
to be able to speak and then you kind of
come to a conclusion um and then you get
to anonymously vote at the end that's
the most involved that I've done that's
baa and uh if that's a thing that you're
interested in my suggestion is go watch
baa like there are so many game awards
shows that there is always going to be
one that you like the voting process for
the game awards is very very very simple
which is like to its credit and not to
its credit it works both ways the game
awards they pick Outlets most of the
time so I did this while I was at IGN
and while I was at Funhouse and the way
it worked at both of those companies was
that we would be sent like a voting form
a Google form to vote um you do get to
pick nominees so we would just take
whatever majority of the staff picked
the nominees that were repeated by the
most staff members would be the ones
that we would then present to the game
awards there was no discussion about it
everybody just got to individually vote
and then whichever game was the most
popular effectively was the one that
made it through and the game awards does
something similar where they just Tally
what the each of the companies who've
already tallied their nominees has sent
over and then the most popular votes get
to become the nominees and then the
Voting is the same thing so we get those
five games back and vote on those five
games and send the votes back to the
game awards doesn't have a jury that has
a discussion there is no room for
collusion because these people don't
even talk to each other let alone know
each other there is no way that this
jury can be biased really like there's
no conversation they are Global there
are people in China there are people in
the Middle East there are people in
South Korea there are people from the
Philippines there people from France
like it's really just a full global
aggregate of what a bunch of popular
outlets in those countries meaning you
know people who are doing this as a job
playing games as a job experiencing
gaming culture as their profession think
is the best game that came out in the
year the same thing applies to like
people saying that they think hogwart's
Legacy didn't get a game of the year
nomination because of politics what
politics like is the implication that
everybody from all over the world has
the the people in Singapore feel the
same way as the people in South Africa
feel the same way as the people in South
Korea feel the same way as the people in
in Turkey basically what the game awards
is is an international popularity
contest and that is usually reflected in
the votes in terms of the games that
have the biggest marketing budgets are
the games that get nominated for Game of
the Year there there are definitely
games that I would have nominated
personally that never would have made it
through even if I were at IGN and I said
I think Dred should be nominated for
game of the year which I do there is no
way that it would have left IGN because
not enough people even in that office
will have played that game they're going
to play the games that are the most
heavily marketed because those are the
games that they know about those are
also usually the games that most Gamers
want to talk about and thus are the ones
that it's more important for people who
work at these companies to make sure
they play like a Spider-Man or a tears
of the Kingdom or clearly bald's gate
which is effectively huge so for all of
the talk all the time of like this got
snubbed at the game awards my thing is
just it's not really what that show is
trying to do or the show would function
differently it is effectively by design
an international popularity contest and
again I think that's fine like it's
totally cool for theame Wars to function
that way it's a lot of fun it means that
you're going to know majority of the
games that are nominated for anything
which is probably better for majority of
the audience who are to be fair very
casual and that's okay that that is the
purpose that this show serves there are
other game awards that focus on
different things that have more hardcore
jewries like baps if you see the games
that come out of adise awards or a GDC
Awards which are much more Dev focused
you'll see very different picks I mean
you'll still often see the big AAA games
because they're the ones that like are
undeniably incredibly High budget
polished do things that a lot of other
Studios can't do but you will see more
variety from uh the devite because those
aren't people who work in an industry
where they need to play every single big
game um often I think a lot of big games
can feel very similar to one another
they're often more interested in playing
games that feel Innovative or that their
peers have told them about and thus are
more likely to play slightly more Niche
games than the media are they're people
serving different purposes their award
serves different purpose but if we
actually pull over what the game awards
has to say about how their nominees are
selected and chosen
just CU they label it themselves but I
don't think a lot of people really read
over this as often as they maybe should
how are nominees selected nominees for
most categories of the game awards are
chosen by an international jury of over
100 Global media and influencer Outlets
selected for the history of critical
video game evaluation specialized juries
also convene for other categories
including orts accessibility and best
adaptation each voting Outlet completes
a confidential unranked ballot based on
the collective and diverse opinion of
its entire editorial stuff which is what
I was saying listing out its top five
choices in each category ballots are
tabulated and the five games that appear
on the most ballots are put forth as
nominees which is again exactly what I
said it's just the most popular games
can I just say this happens all the time
people are like oh Jeff wouldn't let
Starfield because Jeff Lov PlayStation
Jeff doesn't vote Jeff is not on the
jury Jeff does not actually have any say
in what game is voted as Game of the
Year Jeff is not involved in that
process he funds the show he pays for
the show he works in production he does
not vote Jeff has no say he is not
involved in the nominating voting
process at all in fact nobody who isn't
listed on that list of jury has anything
to do with it not Jeff award show Jeff
does a lot he does not choose the
winners and ran game awards producer
Jeff key is not a member of the jury and
does not vote on the nominees or winners
similarly the game awards Advisory board
has no involvement in the awards process
and learns the results at the same time
as the general public why do you use
this jury for select nominees given the
sh number of games released each year as
well as the extended time required to
fully evaluate products a voting Outlet
approach allows for the WID possible
critical assessment which again the game
awards is like explicitly saying that's
their intent right that is what this
show is for is just a really really
broad critical assessment that is what
you should take it as it is not trying
to do anything other than this exact
thing that is the purpose of this
particular show so then winners are
determined by a blended vote between the
voting jury and public fan voting fans
can vote for their favorite games on the
game awards.com and on our Discord
server and I think I've seen that too
people be like it should be entirely fan
voted there are other shows that are
entirely fan voted the game is Awards is
entirely fan voted if that's a thing you
want I would suggest you stop watching
the game awards and watch that show
instead there are so many of them to
pick from in fact I love watching all of
them it's generally really fun I think
Dice and GDC are my personal favorites
but the game WS is always so fun in
terms of like it happens in December
it's the end of the year it's this big
spectacle we get new trailers I don't
know what they are most of the time like
it's it's just a fun celebration and
it's not something that you need to take
seriously and there's this like weird
language surrounding the game awards
specifically where people will go oh
that one game of the year but it's like
what what Outlet there are so many
outlets that do their own game of the
year IGN does their own game of the year
it's a it's a weird thing that I
definitely dislike where people
attribute game of the year to only the
game awards there are so many award
shows I think balers Gate 3 will win at
the game awards I think it will probably
win IGN there will definitely be some
popular Outlets that will give it to
Allan Wake 2 that will give it to Zelda
like it's so weird to act like the game
awards is like the only one when there
are so many award shows and last but not
least this is literally just a series of
people voting right that's what they all
are in the end people not agreeing with
you on it doesn't mean anything it
doesn't mean anything at all it doesn't
have to mean anything just because the
game awards jury who again don't talk to
each other and have no communication and
there's no way of knowing who played
what game and it's super Global and like
the broadest po possible opinion on on
video games voted for something that you
don't agree with doesn't mean anything
it just means that's those people's
opinions and and frankly like part of
when I did this like when we did it for
IGN a fun house it's like very quick
like you're just like oh this like yeah
this one probably i' probably put this
here you're not like sitting down and
being like I must think carefully about
which game produced the most value to
the industry this year I don't know what
that was because it's not part of your
job when you're on this jury you already
have a job usually it's like an end of
day thing where you're like oh yeah
I have to vote for game ons uh this
don't take it so seriously is what I'm
trying to say if the industry does not
agree with you on what wins game of the
year it doesn't mean anything like
that's part of the the cool thing about
video games is we all like different
ones there so many games that have come
out this year that are so fantastic and
people liking different ones to you is
just like a credit to how many good
games there are my main point is just it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't mean anything it doesn't mean
you're wrong it doesn't mean game awards
is Right game awards is not Game of the
Year there are so many award shows that
have game of the year that should be
included in the same conversation and my
big thing at the end is like I watch
Game Awards and I go to game awards to
have fun and I have fun every time it's
just it's a celebration of the industry
it is not an attack on how you feel
about video games personally and taking
it that seriously when I think most of
this jury probably doesn't take it
anyone near that seriously is just silly